relates to what you said about causation
okay why is this this is from kamar 910
why is there something rather than
nothing and lee when you say causation
so physicists obviously study causal
structures like brian mentioned but
those usually mean you're within the
light cone and it's as simple as that
not this caused this so when you have a
model of causation which i'm unsure how
one could formulate that how does that
not lead to an infinite regress or
either an uncaused cause that at some
point especially if you consider time to
be fundamental uh which ties into why is
there something rather than nothing
which is kamar's question
yeah let me give you two cent summary so
the theory paper i'm just finishing with
sarah right now actually tackles that
very question
and and it's except that there are there
at the beginning there is no causation
and but that causation gets baked in
when when information can be stored
about the past that can affect something
differently in the future and it's
really as simple as that and the only
reason physicists have missed it is
because they call screen it out
so all i'm asked all i'm slightly asking
for is to remove entropy
change it to assembly have time going
forward and suddenly you do have causal
cones and those causal cones actually
are limited by the light cone and i
think that brian and i one day will be
talking about assembly cosmology and
we'll be looking for those artifacts out
there but i think we'll we're a little
bit far away from that i need to prove
the theory do the experiments get the
data show the error convince peers
because right now it's just a kind of
cool idea
a bit like lots of things in string
theory and you get that mathematical
structure in reality
and i think we'll be able to but we'll
have to be held account on that so it's
a really good question um but i'm pretty
sure i know where it is
what we're doing right i'm also going to
re-ask you lee so you can expound some
more but brian has to go so brian please
uh so again the question from kumar
again is why is there something rather
than nothing okay so what i thought lee
might say is the why questions are kind
of anathema even though they're the most
interesting questions and the most
natural questions my my toddler will ask
me why why why and of course lee as a
parent kurt doesn't know this yet
because he's not a dad yet but please
god you'll be a father soon uh kurt you
and your lovely wife but lee knows the
ultimate causal chain with an infinite
series of why questions lee how do we
answer our kids
i guess so i mean i just say just tell
them to to look for themselves or to
shut up asking the question right the
answer is why why why why why why why
why because i said so okay there is a
way this regression is
right
because i said so but look you have a
point you have an origin
and you have a cause and effect now the
infinite regress isn't infinite what
happens is this is i just don't want to
this is the mechanism selection so what
this person i'm sorry you have to get
you have to brian has to go and i'm
going to talk to you about so you can
keep talking about that but after brian
goes i i know what it's like to have a
wife that wants you to come immediately
is correct and i do want to see this and
maybe i'll talk with sarah about that
when she comes on my show
but um but ultimately why questions are
not necessarily part of what scientists
should do why implies a meaning and i
think meaning you know will bring up
questions of you know teleological
implications uh and i i don't mean that
they're necessarily anathema but usually
when people ask why they mean how or
what um you know how did how did the
causal chain get established uh those
have great answers in in in cosmology as
well except they have great problems too
and great mysteries and lee alluded to
three hours ago now almost which was you
know how did the whole thing get kicked
off and and what was the initial
generation of you know a a universe and
and so forth you could ask why is there
a universe but i think that the question
of of of why first of all could be
trivial if it didn't exist we wouldn't
be here asking why it doesn't exist um
and uh and and there's your whiskey
that's wonderful i wish i could have
some scottish some scottish coffee at
this time of the day um but uh but in
reality
in cosmology as kurt now you and i
talked you know i only i only have one
regret when it comes to cause that i was
on his channel when it had the square
root of the number of viewers that it
does now and it deserves the square of
the number or if not more uh but uh but
we talked about briefly you know what
are the laws of physics are they
so-called geodesically complete can we
extrapolate the laws and chain of
causality within the light code when you
have a singularity and lee mentioned
singularity a few times i happen to not
to believe that there is a quantum
theory of gravity at least i don't
believe is as well motivated i think
physicists get distracted by it i think
that they're pursuing the theory of
everything for the grandeur the glory
the the accolades that einstein never
lived up to that's the very first
paragraph of michio cocco's new book you
know einstein died with his unfinished
symphony that he couldn't come up with a
theory of everything no despite that
being the name of this channel i think
the gut is almost you know being
overlooked the grand unified theory we
don't understand how the lower energy
forces or the higher energy force are
unified let alone how all four are
unified and who
if not you know uh one of us has the
temerity to say that there has to be a
law of quantum gravity what if there's
not so i'll channel my inner uh you know
lee and and say you know i don't believe
that there is quantum gravity because i
want to inspire my colleagues to think
harder about it and we've been going
about this for decades now with little
signs of progress
not to say to stop even string theory
which i have my problems with um but the
alternative as they say you know the the
string theory is the worst theory except
for all the others that could be true
according to whitten
but but i think ultimately the why
questions are the most interesting but
we should be careful not to ask for
motivation i think that evokes teleology
but but also we should be very precise
we should answer all the how questions
as galileo said
measure what is measurable and make
measurable what is not yet so
and as experimentalists lee and i try to
do that
yeah that's a great way to end it put it
i agree
thank you so much to the both of you i
appreciate it and the audience does as
well
my pleasure thank you kurt and thank you
lee i can't wait to be uh together with
both of you guys at some point in the
near future light cone
and all of the links yeah and all of the
links to lee cronin's and brian
keating's work are in the description
thank you